à dax allemand on n'a pas vraiment de
quand on est dans ces espaces de pouvoir
gens résident plus dans l'hôtel du
ministre fait partie des trois
conseillers qui avaient vraiment
physiquement un accès dire en gros mon
bureau donné directement sur du ministre
par un escalier dérobé qui avait dû être
construit à l'époque pour des histoires
d'amante de courtisanes et c'est donc
j'étais vraiment au coeur du dispositif
dans un palais énorme où il y avait
personne complètement vide et on se rend
compte que que l'accès à l'information
au jour d'aujourd'hui est beaucoup plus
qui fait le coeur du pouvoir qui fait
que normalement c'est ce qui a fait
qu'on a centralisé en fait les instances
de pouvoir dans des lieux comme ça parce
que qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient qu'un
état tenait la nature d'un état c'est un
espace dans lequel tout va remonter tout
va remonter vous allez être capable sur
un territoire donné de savoir ce qui se
passe à l'échelle à cette échelle là et
avoir des informateurs qui vont faire
les informations qui vont faire vous
allez pouvoir prendre une décision et ou
imposer votre autorité est aujourd'hui
dans cette nouvelle période
l'information et la remontée en
infraction sont beaucoup plus éclaté et
le sens même de ces lieux qui ont été
construits de façon très majestueuse
très imposante c'est un peu dissous en
fait donc vous retrouver dans des lieux
qui sont presque des des coquilles vides
ou
où la concentration d'informations
secrètes qui normalement il remonte est
relativement faible donc nos sources
étaient était très divisé il y avait des
sources auxquelles des personnes
n'avaient pas accès extérieurs et
beaucoup des sourds sur lequel on
s'appuyait étaient en fait des sources
publiques qui circulait sur internet et
qui sait comme si le double voilà il y
avait une sorte d'événement comme ça de
ses palais de la république est un
événement qui était transmis vers
internet vers l'espace virtuel le
numérique et dans lequel ces espèces de
pouvoir derrière lequel ces espaces de
pouvoir sont en train de courir en fait
ils vont essayer de grappiller pour
ramener un nouvo recréer une tension
dans les palais de la république et
refaire de ces lieux des lieux de
pouvoir et je suis arrivé à un moment
très très difficile très délicat en
j'imagine qu'à dgse je sais qu'à des gse
boulevard mortier ou même au ministère
de la défense et dans une moindre mesure
à l'elysée la concentration
d'informations confidentielles secrète
qu'elle est vraiment impossible d'avoir
accès reste relativement importante mais
même dans ces espaces là le pouvoir que
donne ne se crée beaucoup plus faible
qu'il était auparavant
sur la syrie qu'est ce que
vous en avez fait remonter votre
expérience personnelle vous avez été sur
le terrain peut vous avez enchaîné
jamais j'étais moi j'étais en fait c'est
ça aussi ça fait intéressant ces postes
là c'est ses responsabilités en fait
sondés sont des lieux où
voilà sept lieux en fait de
concentration d'informations qu'on va
redistribuer et quand vous êtes un
conseiller d'un ministre votre rôle
c'est de filtrer l'information qui va
arriver aux ministres et votre pouvoir
c'est celui là c'est uniquement sur la
cdc du pouvoir votre pouvoir céder marc
de papier c'est paillarès et rien
d'autre sélectionnez vous allez être une
sorte d'entonnoir dans lequel vont
arriver beaucoup d'informations et en
décidant quelle information va remonter
aux décideurs le ministre qui va
lui-même soit décider lui-même soit
participa décision de présenter
république en l'occurrence parce que
même le premier ministre ne participe
pas sur ces sujets vous allez vous allez
influencé cette décision met donc
directement vous avez quasiment aucun
pouvoir vous en avez parfois vous prenez
des décisions à la place du ministre
mais très peu et donc votre rôle va être
de celui de filtres en fait et donc à
partir de là vous ne produisez pas
d'informations ou très peu vous êtes en
réceptacle de personnes qui vont être
sur le terrain des agences et des jantes
et des gse d'autres services des
organisations humanitaires et autres et
vous allez décider qu est ce qui est
pertinent pas pertinent qu'est-ce qui
doit remonter ou pas et là vous allez
faire une petite note à la fin en petits
carrés dont je vais vous dire il faut
prendre telle décision il faut aller
dans cette direction du coup la note la
couleur blanche aux cheveux blancs celle
que par contre dés en fait c'est les
parapheurs qui sont de couleur
particulière c'est vous allez voir des
couleurs roses ou autre selon les visas
qui sont appliqués quand quand on entend
ce qu'ils vont nous dit on peut ce sans
péché de penser qu'il ya aussi une
concentration de prisme de lecture dans
ces institutions
qui ont tendance à un peu donné
à son tour au ministre un prisme de
lecture un petit peu fermé ou polarisée
assez catastrophique surtout qu'en fait
il ya un filtre extrêmement important
sur en france en particulier mais je
pense que ça se reproduit dans notre
pays beaucoup où vous avez des jeunes du
jeune homme qui ont la même formation
qui ont fait les mêmes écoles la plupart
sont énarques on passait pour le quai
d'orsay le concours du quai d'orsay des
formations très stéréotypée qui ont
aucun rapport au terrain pour le coup
qu'à aucun moment sur mis en danger
d'une quelconque façon inouïe qui sont
juste là pour reproduire une vision que
l'on renseigner et il arrive là en fait
avec un seul objectif c'est de se
conformer à la vision préétabli la pré
existante qui s'applique au mont d'or
quand le monde bascule comme par exemple
sur la crise syrienne ces personnes sont
complètement inutiles voire incompétente
et comprendre aux politiques parce
qu'ils vont elles vont essayer de
s'accrocher au modèle antérieur sans
avoir une capacité de création
quelconque donc quand vous arrivez là et
moi c'était ma c'était mon grand drame
pas parce que moi j'avais un peu nous
par exemple j'avais passé juste avant
d'arriver au quai d'orsay c'est pour ça
qu'ils m'ont recruté j'avais passé un
mois au nord kivu sur sur le terrain en
train de rencontrer le groupe rebelle
pour une enquête pour le monde
diplomatique et pour ce qui allait
devenir ma thèse et je m'étais rendu
compte à quel point il ya une
déconnexion immense entre ce que
racontait l ambassade qui était à 2000
kilomètres des lieux où la crise avait
lieu de la direction afrique du quai
d'orsay puis au dessus évidemment des
conseillers qui avaient passé leur vie
dans des palais de la république ou dans
des ambassades et qui avait jamais vus
et qui vous trouvez délirant ni des
mêmes d'aller rencontrer un chef de
groupe rebelle et se retrouver sur un
surnombre août dans un dans une forêt
dans une forêt quasi vierge pour aller
voir ce qui se passait sur le terrain et
alors ils ont quelques agents de la dgse
encore une fois qu'ils vont y aller de
temps en temps ou autre mais ces
personnes là sont très peu nombreuses on
va sombrer généralement peu déployée sur
ces zones qui sont quand même assez
éloigné de la décision est en fait de
fil en aiguille vous créer des
confusions qui s'ils vont créer la
situation syrienne avons créé le
génocide rwandais cetera parce que vous
allez avoir des prismes des lectures
complètement déconnecté de la réalité
génocide rontès intéressant et le rôle
faut pas croire que que
que les responsables politiques de
l'époque ce soit hubert védrine 2001
alain juppé ou même mitterrand avait une
intention de susciter un génocide c'est
pas ça le sujet le sujet c'est qu'ils
étaient tellement débrancher de la
réalité qu'ils ont finit par
participer à ce génocide directement
sous tendant les en soutenant les forces
qu'il commettait et sans à aucun moment
interrogé leur rôle ou alors plus tard
après deux mois et donc pour près de 800
mille morts de d'action et et parce que
il avait été forcé déployer une force
militaire qui elles mêmes sur le terrain
essayez de suivre des ordres qui étaient
complètement aberrant mais qui à un
moment était tellement intenable qui ont
fait remonter même le fait qu'ils ne
pouvaient plus exécuter ses dehors qui
ne pouvait plus participer à la
contribution de crimes de guerre qui
comprend l'unité est là pour le coup
même pour le coup de génocide et qui ils
ont commencé à désobéir et à les aider
des personnes qui est en train de se
faire massacrer à la machette qu'ils
étaient réfugiés dans des collines
depuis depuis trois mois en train de
mourir de faim et que derrière
on soutenait en pensant en pension et je
pense qu'en pensant sincèrement au casse
tête de l'état qu'on était en train de
contribuer à la bonne politique la
conduite et introspective vous l'avez
vue opérées pas du tout au quai d'orsay
y ait eu ou non c'était c'était
extrêmement frustrant et c'est pour ça
que suis parti prudemment ce que je
disais sur ces réunions de service où
tous les mardis à 17 heures je venais je
faisais mon comptabilité macabre mais je
gêne on sait le nombre de mains et ont
passé à autre chose et et voilà c'était
ça et alors que derrière il y avait
laurent fabius qui tenait des discours
extrêmement virulent sur sur le fait
qu'il fallait absolument arrêter ce
scandale qu'on allait intervenir et c
est moi je
jeu complet et je me forçais à
effectuer ce rituel alors que très
clairement c'est susciter une gêne
violente c'est à dire que tout le monde
voyait bien que ça servait à rien mon
niveau personne ne vous n'y pouvez rien
tout le monde avec une envie c'était de
passer à autre chose ne pas de ne pas
avoir à se voir rappeler chaque semaine
ce qui se passait et pour moi c'était
simplement essentiel de montrer par la
dérision presque en disant voilà
aujourd'hui tant de morts et autant de
blessés étant de réfugiés temps ne sais
pas quoi notre position n'a pas changé
les celle là on a fait six ans que c'est
ça on n'a rien fait en fait et 2 et de
créer ce moment jane c'était très
important ces cinq minutes initiales
comme ça va pour les forcer à se rendre
compte que il était à des places de
pouvoir et se satisfaisait même si leur
âme humaine était frustré de ce qui se
passait non c'est pas des citoyens comme
les autres les personnes qui sont assez
place ils ont une responsabilité
particulière qui est si on suit c'est ce
que j'ai essayé de faire dans un texte
qui ont suivi des tic de levinas qu'un
philosophe
juif qui a été très marqué par par la
part évidemment par la question la
seconde guerre mondiale et qui enfin il
ya une éthique de l'infini en fait qui
s'appliquent sur ce canton rentrer en
politique quand vous avez entre vos
mains le destin de milliers centaines ou
milliers millions de personnes vous
pouvez pas vous pouvez pas vous
défausser est en tout cas prétendre que
vous que vous ne savez pas où prétendre
que vous savez donc ne pas en parler il
faut à chaque fois rappelé ses besoins
des tic rappeler cette exigence pour
pour éviter cet effet que créer des
appareils de pouvoir les palais de la
république et c'est qui qui sont faits
pour vous isoler de la société sont
faits pour vous vivre en fait ce que
pour faire vivre en vase clos dans un
dans une virtualité complète où l'idée
même de la mort est complètement absente
on sait pas ce que c'est une marque
quand on travaille là d'un conte s'est
formé là dedans quand elle reste là
dedans on ne sait pas ce que ce qui
implique de changer le code du travail
par ordonnance pour des millions de
personnes c'est des choses qui
c'est c'est des chiffres c'est des idées
c'est à aucun moment quelque chose qui
impacte sa vie en particulier qu'on
allait parcours tellement conformer et
tellement protégés dès le départ qu'on
vu les décideurs en france aujourd'hui
je pense que le système a tenu pendant
assez longtemps
grâce à une chose tout simplement c'est
que les élites politiques de ce pays
sont nées de la résistance après la
seconde guerre mondiale il ya une
constitution de personnes qui ont se
sont mis en danger qui ont connu la
guerre qui ont ou qui ont vu des gens se
mettre en danger leur place et qu'ils
ont et pour lesquels il y avait une
forme de respect naturel qui se créent
et qui elle-même avec idée des
conséquences que pouvoir la politique
sur les gens parce qu'ils avaient vécu
eux mêmes parce que même avait vécu la
politique comme une prise de risques
comme une mise en danger de leur vie et
sa tenue le temps que ces personnes qui
pouvaient être par ailleurs être
politiquement catastrophique où des gens
comme comme pasqua ou autres enfin dont
on sait très bien les dérives qu'ils ont
habité à un moment se retrouver sur ce
coeur qui était de cette expérience
commune et cette compréhension que que
la politique n'est pas un jeu n'est pas
juste un enjeu de carrière d'avancement
de mai qu'ait à un moment elle peut elle
peut mettre elle peut elle peut avoir un
rapport à l'histoire et elle affecte des
vies humaines
au quotidien on fait
ça vous fait quoi de voir
l'arabie saoudite présider le conseil
des droits de l'homme à l'onu
c'est assez compliqué parce que c'est
vraiment une question compliquée parce
qu'il ya
évidemment l'aberration mais essayer de
comprendre comment cette aberration
évitables c'est très difficile d'aider
le moment que que la politique étrangère
aujourd'hui ne vise
qu'une chose c'est enfin vise
principalement une chose c'est une
politique de puissance on voit sur la
question du blocage du blocus qui
s'applique au qatar aujourd'hui où on a
tous les médias sont enfoncer les portes
ouvertes y compris montrent de façon
très intéressante en reprenant les
éléments de langage sur le fait que le
qatar financier est de 10 me moi quand
j'étais au quai d'orsay en 2013 il y
avait eu un télégramme diplomatique très
intéressant qui était venue d'une
rencontre avec le conseiller national à
la sécurité
l'arabie saoudite qui était un prince
qui était un tout peut être tout
puissant qui est parti deux ans plus
tard qu'ils étaient débarqués parce que
justement il avait pris de l'ensemble du
pouvoir et qui racontait de façon très
très légère ou à l'ambassadeur qui était
allé le le voir avec le conseiller a et
nemo afrique du nord moyen orient de du
président de la république français qui
racontait que l'arabie saoudite avec
contrôle sur 85 à 90% des groupes armés
agissant en syrie quand on connaît la
nature des groupes armés qui agissent en
syrie aujourd'hui quand on voit surtout
ce qu'elle est devenue ce qu'ils sont
devenus qui était au départ une des
tendances laïciste et c'est que tu es
progression écrasé par par les forces
les plus confessionnelles il ya deux
choses en fait il ya d'une part en 2013
on accepte de ce que ce qui est dit et
on continue à livrer à ces groupes armés
des armes à travers l'arabie saoudite
c'est toujours comme ça que ça s'est
fait l'arabie saoudite et continuent à
acheter des armes à la france pour
livrer à ces groupes armés pour que la
france ne soit pas impliqué directement
donc on utilise le canal france
n'apparaisse comme et participe en droit
un conflit armé ce qui serait en
contravention des règles de droit
international qui l'exposerait aussi
directement et donc on utilise l'arabie
saoudite à la fois comme véhicules et
aussi comme financeur ce qui permet à
nos comme proxy peut-être vos comme
proxy mais aussi comme financeur qui
nous qui permet aussi à nos à notre
industrie de l'armement de continuer à
exister et à être autonome
donc on utilise ça en sachant
parfaitement que l'arabie saoudite est
le principal vecteur aujourd'hui de
financement du salafisme et des dieux et
via le wahhabisme des des courants les
plus extrémistes et les plus violents de
l'islam de d'islam religieux et
politiques
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on fait ça
est ce qu'on est ce qu'on est ce qu'on a
la naïveté de croire que on a un
contrôle suffisant sur l'arabie saoudite
pour qu'à aucun moment l'arabie saoudite
viennent utiliser ces groupes armés pour
transmettre son influence et les
transformer en mouvements
fondamentalistes est ce qu'on s'en fout
est-ce qu'on le fait volontairement ça
je crois pas cette dernière hypothèse
mais en tout cas il ya très clairement
enfin on lit ces télégrammes
diplomatiques jeudi 7 à g politique à ce
moment je me dis mais comment est-ce que
ça c'est qu'il n'a aucune réaction qu
est-ce qu à quoi est-ce qu'on joue et
quand on voit que dans ce même
télégramme diplomatique ce prince dix
mille qatar ils font les malins mais il
ne contrôle que 10% des groupes armés
sur place et que l'on voit cinq ans plus
tard quand la leur avis audit justifie
son blocus sur le qatar parce que le
qatar financerait le terrorisme on voit
très bien que
tout ça c'est des jeux de dupes en fait
on a on est sur une zone du territoire
où l'existence même de ces états répond
à des impératifs géopolitique et
notamment de contrôle des ressources
l'arabie saoudite n'existe que parce que
elle est un pôle de stabilité qui permet
après deux aux états unis et à l'europe
maintenant la chine de d'avoir des
approvisionnements en pétrole
suffisant idem pour le qatar les qataris
comme état indépendant parce qu'il a des
ressources de gaz qui font que le
pouvoir n'est pas trop concentré dans un
seul état et l arabie saoudite ne se
retrouve pas en position ou des émirats
arabes unis qui pourraient aussi un
moment intégré de kata ne se retrouve
pas en position de pouvoir faire du
chantage ou s'opposer aux états unis et
être donc on est sur des sur des espaces
qui n'ont pas de qui n'ont pas
d'existence politique réelle ils ont ils
ont ainsi distance instrumentale ils
servent à lille servent à des objectifs
à des moyens de grande puissance leur
histoire ne justifie pas leur existence
ils n'ont pas de culture particulière
ils n'ont pas de quand on voit l'arabie
saoudite s'est enfin c'est juste un un
émirat qui était créé une principauté à
un royaume maintenant royaume mais bon
au départ qui était créée il ya sept ans
par une famille de herbert qui décide et
enfin pas de berbères pardon de
ses pas de sujet mais en tout cas qui
ont décidé de prendre le pouvoir sur un
espace et que qui n'avaient pas
d'ancrage particulier dessus auparavant
donc on est sur des constructions comme
sa géopolitique qui servent des intérêts
et qui font que ma place et l'arabie
saoudite au conseil des droits de
l'homme de l'onu un moment si c'est le
prix à payer pour avoir leur
complaisance sur tel ou tel autre sujet
pour pouvoir continuer à assurer une
sorte de contrôle dessus finalement
est-ce que c'est très dur est-ce que
c'est très différent et une grande
question là dessus à ce que le continuum
quand on a une telle proximité une telle
fusion entre l'arabie saoudite et les
etats unis et de réseaux moindre mesure
la france il ya un continuum petits
secrets est ce que je pense est-ce que
la france est devenue une puissance de
de faible puissance
non je pense que la france a une grande
puissance aujourd'hui une grande
capacité à le tournoi néo conservateur
qui a pris la france à partir de nicolas
sarkozy qui a complètement basculé là
la géopolitique du moyen-orient
accompagner un moment où justement où
les tajines essayer de sortir de ceux de
sept jours une parenthèse logique est ce
que vous vous rappelez des accords
méditerranéen lesquels ceux de l'union
pour la méditerranée 200 crédit en 2007
c'est un projet intéressant cette idée
de dire que on a d'un côté l'allemagne
car nintendo qui va être l'europe de
l'est dans lequel il s'est construit une
sorte de tissu économique ou ou en gros
elle par toute une série d' équilibre
elle délocalise ses industries pour
regarder toute la valeur ajoutée et qui
fait que l'allemagne et à force
économique actuel on valide et de ce que
j'ai compris de nicolas sarkozy au
départ enfin en tout cas ses conseillers
s'étaient faire la même chose sur
l'espace méditerranéen
sens avec ce petit oubli khedir bah oui
enfin sauf que dans l'espace
méditerranéen à l'époque et un certain
nombre de dictature et de régimes qui
sont très distanciée de 2d standard qui
pourrait s'appliquer en europe mais
derrière en fait une vision purement
géopolitique qui est de dire on va on va
passer au tout ça et nous on va se
construire en tant que puissance encore
une fois c'est une politique de
puissance la question des droits de
l'homme c'est cette idée de dire en tout
cas dans cet esprit là c'est non nous
c'est depuis cette pratique des droits
de l'homme on ne peut l'appliquer que si
on en a les moyens que si on est une
puissance suffisante qui va pouvoir
derrière à avoir une politique
d'influencé qui va faire que d'abord en
france progressivement ensuite on va
pouvoir généraliser ce modèle on a vu le
succès de cette vision avec le
colonialisme et et d'autres aventures
mais en tout cas il ya toujours cette
justification qui fait que la question
des droits de l'homme en soit c'est elle
va toujours apparaître après la question
des cosmétiques pas cosmétique mais dans
un an
elle va être relégué un second un second
temps ou en tout cas un second rôle de
serre d'abord la politique de puissance
ensuite la question des droits de
l'homme si on arrivait la question d'un
puissant devons donc d'abord si on a par
exemple si on apprit pouvoir sur tel
territoire que ce soit de facto en tout
cas sous le boisseau à ce moment là on
va essayer de produire un politique
humanitaire de trois dom etc sauf qu'en
général quand une puissance étrangère
mais sous tutelle un territoire donné de
facto il ya une tension très forte si je
résume le résonance et les droits de
l'homme coûte du pognon il nous faut du
pognon pour pouvoir les féroé c'est
plutôt l inverse ça c'est que tant que
enfin il faut l'argent pour faire des
droits de l'homme
donc c'est un système capitaliste
intégré et creton depuis d'argent si je
retourne le raisonnement il faut revenir
à une politique de puissance il faut
reprendre le pouvoir bien sûr et donc on
va on va aller à avoir une politique
offensive qui va permettre enfin qu'il
de l'invasion de la guerre en irak à
d'autres fins va faire qu'on va on va
reprendre l'état d'urgence ce que l'état
d'où ils ont fait sauter du coq à l'âne
encore des soft aujourd'hui
des tas urgence c'est
c'est une question assez
en fait moi ça m'intéresse beaucoup
parce que j'ai beaucoup suivi tous les
travaux qui ont qui ont donné naissance
à au mouvement anarchiste et autonome
et notamment aussi au comité invisible
et c'est avec un peu dirigé par julien
coupat qui en fait puisé à une source
que j'ai bien connue qui écrit un petit
livre très longs poils qui vient de
sortir à ne plus y annoncer maintenant
le dernier qui est sorti et je veux un
coup passer quelqu'un intéressant parce
que c'est quelqu'un que départ est un
intellectuel et qui se construit
vraiment dans une élite intellectuelle
très structuré qui est tournée doit lui
achever cesse donc l'école parisienne
autour d'un grand philosophe qui
s'appelle juin gamble qui est un
philosophe italien qui est le grand
penseur avec alain badiou de la gauche
de la gauche et donc et il se construit
autour de lui avec cette ambition
initiale d'être un grand intellectuel et
avec une bataille très forte avec celui
qui est devenu un des grands philosophes
aujourd'hui notre temps qui s'appelle
mehdi belhaj belkacem qui lui qu'on
gagne en fait la fidélité d'agamben et
réussi à s'imposer sur la scène
intellectuelle comme étant une forme
d'héritiers autres avec quelques autres
quentin meillassoux et quelques uns
julien coupat de cette défaite va tirer
une sorte de repli stratégique qui va
commencer à construire tarnac et
quelques amis eva eva et va s'orienter
vers ce qui est plutôt
la question active c'est à dire la lutte
active la lutte sur le terrain pas à
partir avec un lien très fort aux idées
c'est pour ça que les textes du comité
invisible sont très riches et très
littéraire mais en gardant cette idée
que que c'est il ya deux voies en fait
qu'ils se construisent en dissensions
mais pour se rejoindre un moment à la
fois la construction théorique
intellectuels du monde de demain et la
voix active les sabotages et la
participation à des blacks blocs ces
derniers temps aux manifestations avec
des stratégies à sédières et là on est
dans un mouvement
pourquoi j'en parle parce que l'état
d'urgence en fait se construit en en en
équivalence presque avec ces mouvements
qui sont en train de naître qui commença
à prendre pied dans les années dans des
zones en fait les at c'est très
intéressant et les actes c'est quand
même des zones je vais vous expliquer
comment est ce qu'on arrive après la fin
de résonance et un peu c'est un salaire
consumer mais ça donc on a on a on à
julien coupat on a on a des théoriciens
des grands théoriciens de l'extrême
gauche de la gauche de la gauche d'une
société anarchique anarchiste on sait
pas enfin un anarchiste autonomistes
avec un retour qui propose un retour à
la commune en tout cas une
déstructuration de l'état qui est
propose de sortir du modèle de l'état de
l'autorité de l'état du la république
etc on a deux mamelles on a la même l
intellectuel on à la mamelle activistes
en attaque et badiou belhaj kacem ben
c'est de la soie viennent de la même
source et vont se rejoindre un moment
donc ça on a ça on a après des
mouvements qui proviennent de milieux
militants activistes éjecte résistants
l'écologie souvent qui ont commencé à
créer sur le territoire des espaces dont
l'objectif des z et qu'il devienne à
terme inviolable à notre dame des landes
as events et ses espaces où les pouvoirs
publics la police ne peut pas rentrer à
terme c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire et
pour cela on est prêts à mettre en
oeuvre une stratégie de la tension
contre tension donc les forces de
l'ordre qui viennent déloger avec des
méthodes d'une brutalité inouïe et
al'inverse des des militants qui pour
une partie d'entre eux notamment ceux
qui viennent de cette mouvance anarcho
autonome comme les appellent les
pouvoirs vont essayer de provoquer une
stratégie de tension pour les pousser à
la faute pour les pousser à la faute et
quand il y aura faute du coup rendre
inviolable de cet espace c'est ce qui
s'est passé notamment avec la faire une
fresque il ya à partir du moment où
kelly ont bien mort dans cette situation
l'état ne peut plus rien il est
complètement désactivé et surtout un
jeune fin dans des situations
complètement scandaleuse avec
l'utilisation d'armes de guerre comme
des grenades grenades offensives on en
parle comme ça dans les médias c'est une
grenade c'est une grenade comme quand on
joue à call of duty vous balancer une
grenade a explosé vous tuer quelqu'un
c'est fait pour ça c'est fait pour tuer
et on va lancer sur un fondement je veux
simplement grenat de simplement c'est
des grenades offensives en fait c'est
des grenades qui expose matières
explosives équipe et qui tuent quoi
enfin c'est pas un accident ce qui
arrive donc on est dans cette tension
mais qui du coup fait que sylvain ce
derrière un intouchable c'est bon
d'abandonner projet et c'est donc on
commence à voir des enclaves qui
commencent à se créer sur le territoire
où il ya une inviolabilité où
l'état n'a plus d'emprise qu'il aurait
pu avoir sur cet espace on se retrouve
avec des manifestations qui sont encore
dans une phase préliminaire qui sont
exprimées par le travail vous avez des
syndicats qui essaie de jouer leur rôle
qui continuent encore à tenir plus ou
moins le rôle alors qu'ils sont ils ont
de moins en moins de pouvoir mais qui
avec l'appui de forces comme la france
insoumise
tiennent là pour contestation de façon
dans le système c'est à dire qu'elle
vise à faire basculer le pouvoir s'en
ressent sans destitué le pouvoir il vise
assure une mission une mesure donné à
faire céder le pouvoir sauf que là
dedans commence à s'infiltrer des
groupes les black blocks à julien coupat
qui était dans chaque manifestation qui
crée des stratégies tensions et
violences pour susciter à nouveau
l'incident à un incident similaire à
celui qui serait intervenu dans des
adeptes ces éléments perturbateurs c'est
des éléments qui sont pas vous catr
c'est oui une stratégie de provocation
mais qui assume et qui assume et qui
vise justement parce que par ailleurs on
a un pouvoir qui est de plus en plus
bête et plus en plus violents à le
mettre face à ses limites et à en
montrer et a provoqué l'effondrement
donc y rentrer et là ils sont dans la
stratégie c'était une stratégie initiale
qui était on apparaît très clairement
comme différencier de la masse donc avec
les cagoules avec eux en étant en tête
de cortège en contrôlant cortège et c
est moi ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup
c'est que là on arrive à un moment où la
verticale du pouvoir devient tel avec
macron la violence qui est en train de
de s'appliquer à la fois socialement et
politiquement devient extrêmement forte
avec les ordonnances les ordonnances le
rappelle c'est un énarque qui décide
quels ce que va être la loi et le
parlement obéit il ya plus de débat il
ya plus de députés etc donc on se
retrouve dans cette situation là où le
pouvoir par ailleurs état d'urgence avec
des perquisitions genre et donc on en
arrive là avec des perquisitions qui
peuvent est décidée par le préfet le
préfet c'est le représentant du
gouvernement c'est à dire que demain le
ministre l'intérieur
gérard collomb on demande à un préfet
d'aller perquisitionner un journaliste
un écologiste ou quoi que ce soit le
préfet d'obéir sinon il doit ouvrir une
semaine grave parce qu'il n'a pas être
arrêté derrière mais quoique avec
l'assignation à résidence ou après
éventuellement la création de qu'enfin
il ya tout une chose qui peut susciter
la ne rentrons pas dans le tronc pas
dans l'anticipation restons juste sur ce
qui existe schiste qui va exister demain
c'est parce qu'en fait la réalité se
suffit à elle même c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on peut commencer
par un journaliste de la pqr au nous
voyons un petit indignation de faire
beaucoup et peur progressivement la
chose va s'étendre donc on est sur cette
émergence où il ya une tension qui va
devenir de plus en plus difficile de
l'autre par des politiques économiques
et sociales qui ont été décidées sans
assentiment populaire et a priori selon
les sondages contre l'avis de la
majorité de la population dès lors à
partir de septembre des manifestations
qu'est ce qu'elle veut la population et
on sait pas mais en tout cas elle veut
pas ça a priori de ce conseil c'est déjà
sur le web comme briand le savez est à
priori à fortiori sur le pardon et à
fortiori sur cette loi nathan et
j'arrivais à la fin du raisonnement on
arrive sur sur un mois de septembre dans
lequel il va y avoir évidemment une
contestation face à ces décisions qui
vont être prises et un gouvernement qui
risquent de se retrouver sans
interlocuteur parce que il a essayé
d'écraser la france sont soumises parce
que les syndicats sont faibles à
françois soumise à peu d'élus etc et là
jean luc mélenchon je vous ne sera tj
très très délicate où il essaie de se
renforcer et là il est rentré à
l'assemblée en gueulant pour essayer de
de reprendre la place parce que s'il
n'existe plus qu'est ce qui se passe on
se retrouve face à une manifestation de
gens très modérée mais qui veulent juste
pas de cette loi travail etc et on se
retrouve aussi avec ces groupes très
structuré politiquement qui commence à
être parle quand même de 3000 à 4000
personnes à chaque manifestation donc
c'est quand même une masse importants
qui peuvent décider demain sur
instigation de julien coupat depuis une
l2 un autre membre du comité risquent de
perdre leurs atours de black blocks de
perdre la cagoule c'est de fusionner
dans la masse de provoquer à partir de
la dette dans un rapport de tension par
rapport à nos forces de police d'oslo
n'a jusqu'à chercher d'incidents et à ce
moment là qu'est ce qui se passe est ce
que c'est la france insoumise est ce que
ces syndicats une fois par exemple
disons il ya un mort de manifestations
de septembre que fait le pouvoir que
fait le pouvoir est ce qu il va s qu il
cède alors qu'il s'est fait élire sur
sur sa détermination à réformer naalin
alors qu'il a fait voter une loi d'ordre
ainsi il peut pas céder est-ce qu'il
peut céder sur certains points mais non
il ya plus d'interlocuteur il ya deux
majorités absolues il a pu les syndicats
sont décrédibilisés la france soumise
est faible qu'est ce qui se passe ils
sont obligés de continuer à passer en
force ils sont obligés de passer en
force et si julien coupat et compagnie
une intelligence de la situation
ils font ils vont aller dans ses
stratégies vont à sa stratégie de mise
sous tension du poids requis à faire le
pouvoir va être obligé passer en force
et leur lutte devient soudain
majoritaire parce que s'il ya un gosse
de 22 ans qui meurent de à paris demain
dans une manifestation et que le
pourrait quand même temps vous avez un
pouvoir qui peut pas reculer parce qu'il
est pris dans sa dans une stratégie qui
enfin parce qu'il est pris en fait dans
ce qui fait sans fondement ce qui fait
ça le fondement de son pouvoir et qu'il
a par ailleurs c'est donner les
instruments d'aller très loin avec
l'état d'urgence avec déployer une
violence extrêmement grande vous êtes
dans une explosion vous êtes dans un
dans un enjeu où tout d'un coup le seul
la seule possibilité c'est la
destitution du pouvoir c'est la
destitution de pouvoir c'est quoi c'est
l'objectif du comité invisible depuis
des années où l'écrasement des
grincements de dents de scie
l'écrasement met du coup dans cette
logique dans cette logique on en fait
vous avez deux pôles alors que jusque là
on pouvait penser que c'est des
mouvances anarchistes qui était pas
magique où tout d'un coup en fait la
politique devient un enjeu entre un
pouvoir autoritaire et des personnes qui
veulent renverser ce pauvre et vous êtes
dans une situation révolutionnaire au
pré révolutionnaire donc l'état
d'urgence participent à cette à ses
créations d'une tension et ce
déploiement d'une tension extrêmement
forte la société ou dans la situation
actuelle ça peut susciter basculement en
fait un peu d'anticipation et de
prospective
moi oui en faisant cela on va bien sûr
l'aï laissé là et ça va dépendre en fait
d'être une chose à nouveau c est ce que
aujourd'hui la france est soumise et
mélenchon vont être capables d'aggloméré
autour d'eux une légitimité une force
suffisante pour faire que ce ne soit pas
les ses autres mouvances qui prennent en
fait cette place là et qui est
entamé un rapport de force avec le
système à l'intérieur du système pour
l'empêcher devriez et dès lors de
s'effondrer c'est pas du tout sûr qu'il
y arrive comment vous modélisez
d'effondrement ah ça c'est impossible à
prévoir après les formes de
l'effondrement si l'effondrement il ya
où l'écrasement comme vous le dites que
ce soit sous une forme ou une autre à
part par le fait que ça va être ça
serait violent ya pas qu il n'y a pas
deux il n'y a pas de capacité à établir
à l'avance la forme que prend une
révolution une révolte une émeute c'est
toujours indéterminable et ça dépend en
fait d'une d'une série de micro
décisions c'est un rigolo monde mon
directeur de campagne pendant la
législature ça
un doctorow un doctorant à yale qui
travaille sur la révolution tunisienne
et qui essaie de tirer de la révolution
tunisienne un modèle qui permette de
comprendre en fait comment comment la
révolution il s'appelle jean baptiste
gallopin comment comment comme la
révolution on lui qu'est ce qui fait
qu'à un moment il ya une bascule qui
fait que ce qui jusque là était une
émeute ou un
pardon pas en tire pas l'anti rui bien
sur eux oui bien sûr ceux propres c'est
joyeux ça fait partie des fait partie
des instances paraétatiques en fait
parce qu'on dit si une instance privée
et c'est quelque chose qui fonctionne
quand même avec la
cie n'ont l'appui du moins l'accord de
l'état et qui permettent en fait à la
france c'est pareil c'est une politique
de ressources à nouveau qui permettent
de rentrer de s'instiller dans les dents
les dans les territoires étrangers avec
des moyens par anigo qui permettent à la
france de ne pas s'exposer directement
comme étant celle qui vend du matériel
ou des logiciels qui permettent
d'espionner et qui en même temps permet
de maintenir sa stratégie d' influence
évidemment qu'est ce que vous faites
quand vous êtes la dgse ou leur dit
écoutez les gars fait que vous voulez
mais derrière on veut on veut l'accès
c'est un peu la géopolitique des câbles
sous marins ça c'est un autre sujet mais
joe pesci des câbles sous-marins c'est
assez particulier parce que certes vous
avez un pouvoir important quand vous
quand les câbles sous-marins vous
vous appartiennent enfin c'est toujours
plus facile d'aller d'un backbone
directement du cou et de tirer
l'information de là mais on sait très
bien qu'il ya des capacités
d'infiltration et de saisine de
l'information auprès de câbles qui vous
reçoit lequel vous avez pas accès à
l'infrastructure dans son ensemble donc
donc c'est un élément stratégique
important et géostratégiques important
après on est arrivé à un tel niveau de
sophistication des appareils de
renseignements que le contrôle
économique et et de sueur sur ces
organisations n'est pas n'est pas
essentiel et peut-être jean d'état
d'urgence et terrorisme
qu'est ce que vous pensez du terrorisme
islamiste
en france
le dernier attentat la moitié avorté
d'hier
cette jolie fumée jaune qui sortait de
cette voiture
moi une des raisons principales pour
lesquelles quand je pars quand je parle
du quai d'orsay que je démissionne et
que et que j'écris quand en particulier
que c'est à propos de la syrie j'ai
écrit une lettre où j'explique que on
peut pas être sur un discours dans
lequel on condamne et on voue aux
gémonies le pouvoir de bachar el-assad
et de la série et on équivaut à un
diable 100 derrière
avoir un avoir enfin comme être enfin
agir en fait tout simplement dire que on
peut pas créer une tension telle éthique
chez les français dans lesquels on leur
dit il ya quelque chose de
catastrophique et horrible est en train
d'arriver en même temps on fait rien
contre parce que qu'est-ce que vous
faites sinon vous délégitimer la parole
de l'état l'état c'est quand vous êtes
quand vous vous détenez le pouvoir
d'état votre discours de toujours être
accompagnés d'actes il doit toujours
être performatif si vous parlez et
qu'après vous n'agissez pas la croyance
s'effondre et la croyance est ce qui
permet à l'état de tenir un état n'a pas
mis à francine ya corée du nord n'ont un
policier derrière chaque personne pour
s'assurer que elle fait bien ce qu'il
veut enfin elle respecte bien le moindre
règles et lois règlements et même faim à
travers bien à tous les feux rouges etc
vous obéissez le citoyen n'importe qui
obéit à l'état et aux règles qui
s'imposent dans le vivre ensemble quand
il considère qu'il y ait un risque
suffisant que ils se fassent avoir par
les tacles et à une autorité suffisante
pour l'avoir moment avec le coût à payer
soit trop important la croyance est au
fondement du pouvoir d'état dire que
vous donnez l'impression que vous allez
pouvoir vous imposer à l'autre si vous
si vous perdez cette croyance dans cette
soumission
enfin ces croyances qui permet à la
soumission vous vous effondrez l'état
c'est l'état c'est ces quelques
bâtiments à paris c'est super facile
enfin c'est rien c'est quelques
bâtiments à paris c'est quelques
dizaines de milliers de policiers
peut-être quelques centaines oublié je
ne sais même pas c'est impossible de
tenir un pays est encore aujourd'hui
c'est plus facile qu'il ya 500 ans mais
ça fait 5 sans que l'état de france
existent quand vous étiez sous louis xiv
il n'y avait même pas mis les policiers
sur tout le territoire français pourtant
le territoire français fonctionner comme
territoire et ainsi une emprise sur ce
pouvoir un essai de l'expérience de
milgram oui bien sûr sur la question
mais surtout qu'elle a eue au yen si je
me suis un bien donc ça fait partie des
grandes des grandes
enfin des grands mythes qui existe là
bas quand vous y arrivez mai mais je
reviens laissez moi finir là-dessus sur
la question du de la croyance et de la
soumission dès lors que vous avez un
discours qui dit il ya le diable aux
portes de chez nous il faut absolument
s'en débarrasser mais que vous faites
rien vous suscitez des fuites vous
mettez en tension vos citoyens qui
croient en vous qui croie à votre parole
et qu'avant 10 mais comment ça se fait
qu'on ne fasse rien il faut faire
quelque chose nous et si l'état ne fait
rien il faut que je fasse quelque chose
pour moi une des grandes explications
des centaines de français qui sont
partis en syrie
c'est une seule explication à ses fins
c'était attendu mais c'est que ces
personnes ont vu ont vu leurs discours
valider ce discours valider ou dans
laquelle il fallait aller faire la
guerre sainte en syrie parce qu'elle est
un diable était tard ils ont vu valider
par les discours de laurent fabius de
françois hollande etc qui ne proposait
pas les moyens de mettre en action ses
discours donc à partir du moment de ce
moment quand vous avez une organisation
qui derrière vous dit mais moi je te
proposait faire la guerre sainte moi je
te propose d'aller se débarrasser de ce
diable moi je te propose d'aller régler
cette situation et devrait pour le bien
commun ces personnes là qui pour des
raisons d autres n'ont pas forcément à
distance suffisante par rapport à l'est
surtout à l'époque on ne savait pas
encore il y avait encore la possibilité
il y avait une robinho modérée des états
se laisse porter se laisse porter et
vont vers vers ces espèces là et dès ce
moment là vous avez un effondrement
partiel de l'autorité tatic avec un
concurrent qui n'est qui est l'état
islamique et avec tous ces vers tentes
et qui va être en mesure de lui même de
à nouveau rien filtrer donc pouvoir
enfin l'état français pour renvoyer ses
soldats pour combler cette faiblesse et
qui a été créée par pas le décalage
entre discours et l'action donc je pense
qu'on porte une responsabilité très
forte on a un discours moral très
important très très fort sur la question
syrienne on est on s'est montré
complètement impuissant et donc
évidemment une partie des citoyens ce
qui pour une raison ou une autre était
le plus vulnérable et plus les plus
exposés aux discours radicaux islamistes
etc ont décidé de s'engager dans cette
voie et donc à partir de là on a créer
nous mêmes une sorte de monstre qui ne
pouvait qu un moment revenir vers nous
pour s'imposer pour simple pour pour
essayer de reprendre le pouvoir sur les
places même où l'état avait montré son
effondrement
est ce que vous comprenez que l'état
français puissent modéliser les
mouvements d'extrême gauche ou d'extrême
droite comme des mouvements islamistes
parce que il propose une alternative il
propose d'aller combattre un étage il
est assez naïve beaucoup plus violent
avec l'extrême gauche avec l'extrême
droite parce que l'extrême gauche impose
une menace pour la forme et à ce n'est
pas du tout le cas d'extrême droite
l'extrême droite vise à prendre le
pouvoir de l'état à renforcer l'état et
l'extrême gauche vise à démanteler
l'état enfin en tout cas cet écran
gauche dont on parlait tout à l'heure
son objectif assez claire et assumée
c'est de ces deux décomposer la forme
états pourront composer d'autres femmes
politiques à l'échelle de la commune et
ses parts dès lors il est naturel quand
vous êtes à l'intérieur de l'état
d'appliquer votre violence non pas sur
des questions idéologiques mais sur des
questions de qui est-ce qui va menacer
votre monopole sur la violence légitime
votre force votre forme en fait donc que
ce soit les islamistes ou d'extrême
gauche il ya naturellement continuum qui
va se former évidemment il klein qui est
détenteur de la violence légitime
théoriquement donc n'importe quelle
menace sur ses nuances des victimes va
se voir appliquer cette violence
légitime avec la même violence fichier s
pardon vous êtes fichés s
aucune idée de demander enfin je sais qu
enfin je sais c'est évident que pour
toute une série de raisons que je suis
quelque part et que je suis mieux
ça m'étonne en fait ça me ça me
trouverais ça et c'est naturel que je
sois fille chez elle et que votre copine
sous un fichu parce que vous êtes fichés
et que et que la coiffeuse de votre
copine votre grand-mère soit fiché en
fait après ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'ils n'ont pas besoin de faire ça
parce qu'ils ont des algorithmes et des
dispositifs de surveillance de masse
font qu'une fois que vous avez une cible
légitime entre guillemets vous pouvez
signer toutes les autres par ricochet
sans avoir à les intégrer au système
donc ça à partir de là c est non il ya
aucune naturalité à
je considère légitime que l'état
considère que j'ai pu constituer une
menace à son encontre parce que je
travaillais avec wikileaks même si je
les fais comme dans l'équipe de défense
et par l'intérieur de wikileaks je
considère que c'est normal je dis pas
que je défends cette position vu que
j'en suis heureux mais je considère
normal que l'état un moment et décider
de se protéger on peut s'assurer en plus
j'ai trahi au quai d'orsay n'a eu accès
des infos ils sont très sensibles et qui
est pour moi il faut pas se placer sur
au niveau de la morale sur ces sujets
c'est la même façon sur la question des
lanceurs d'alert de routine de ce que
fait wikileaks est un canton quand on
s'engage sur c'est sur ces questions on
prend un risque et on assume
parfaitement on assume parfaitement pour
un risque on sait très bien vers quoi
envers qu'on avance et contre quoi on
s'oppose ça veut pas dire qu'il faut pas
lutter contre ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut défendre c'est qu'il ne faut pas
défendre ses droits etc il faut savoir
savoir que des moments que vous mettez
en danger un pouvoir
parce que il a commis des excès et c'est
ce pouvoir va essayer d'empêcher qu'on
le mette en danger et va s'assurer que
va faire on va tout faire son possible
pour préserver justement ça sa position
donc à partir de là moi je pense qu'il
ya 2 je comprends le discours victimaire
qui est très important pour eux pour
obtenir l'appui public parce que ça fait
parti des luttes tout simplement comme
quand tarnac julien coupat compagnies
ont décidé de faire tout un tout un tout
une stratégie de communication à travers
le monde notamment à caen ils sont
inculpés pour terrorisme et je suis d
complètement d'accord avec ce qu'il en
fait par contre il faut avoir conscience
que c'est un moyen de but c'est pas
c'est pas la finalité on voit
ce qu'on fait et d'une violence extrême
pour ces appareils dont on les met à nu
on met à nu des personnes qui se croyait
complètement protégé dans des tours
d'ivoire dans lesquelles ils ont commis
des crimes et des actes immoraux etc et
on est tout d'un coup on les expose
alors qu'ils pensaient être complètement
protégé comment est ce que c'est normal
que ces dispositifs s'activent pour
empêcher la mise en visibilité de ça
après nous il faut lutter pour que c'est
pour qu'on puisse continuer mais il faut
on sera toujours dans le domaine de la
lutte il faut pas il faut pas croire que
que yare un monde dans lequel il y
aurait des dispositifs et donc comme
vous êtes dans le domaine de la lutte
vous appliquez mais un minimum de
stratégie de modélisation d'anticipation
meilleur il faudra qu'elles sont quel
sens quels sont les facteurs aggravants
quels sont les paramètres de ce système
que vous modélisez en priorité au moins
c'est trop
c'est trop intuitif en fait comme
travail s'avère qu'il ya pas deux il n'y
a pas de prêt enfin y'a pas de modèles
coiffés pas d'arborescence ya pas de la
pinière non non il n'y a pas de de
système nerveux non parce que moi en
plus j'ai une formation et un habitus
qui fait que je connais très bien les
appareils de pouvoir de l'intérieur
quand je parle de facteurs à surveiller
c'est par exemple de la démographie le
production d'être le taux de natalité
face à
toutes ces analyses ont quant à elles
sont prêtes elles sont pas produites
dans un cadre universités afin moi j'ai
un quadrille austère très particulier
sur les violences de masse et la
violence politique mais ça c'est assez
spécifique par contre si pas emmanuel
todd terre que je ne produis pas une
analyse politique
universitaire et donc toutes ces années
ils ont ont passé des analyses qui sont
menées dans un cadre soit militants
soient politiques sur l'activité qui à
partir elles n'ont pas besoin d'être
modéliser ou d'être justifiée il faut
c'est pas ça c'est l'heure je me suis
mal exprimé je me posais la question
vous êtes dans un cadre de lutte on va
modéliser sa stratégie militaire
c'est-à-dire qui dit lutz 10
interceptions de renseignement en amont
pour voir prendre la température et
adapter sa stratégie si la passe ce type
de stratégie
votre mouvement et simplement condamnés
à réagir d'une façon symptomatique donc
les facteurs aggravants vous pouvez
modélisés en face de vous qui pourrait
accentuer ou de voir accentuent évolué
depuis cependant ils sont
institutionnelle en fait d'abord faire
comme moi moi je parle je pense beaucoup
à terme vous avez compris ouais moi je
pense beaucoup en termes de structure en
fait de structures de pouvoir justement
de respect pour ça que je mentionnais
cette chose sur l'habitude c'est la
connaissance intérieur des pouvoirs qui
est très importante et moi si j'ai une
valeur ajoutée dans ce rapport de force
qui existe entre entre ceux qui
s'engagent comme doux pour tout
simplement rendre un monde put enfin où
justement les pouvoirs soient inhibés et
on est des contre-pouvoirs plus
important c'est cette connaissance de
l'intérieur très forte non seulement des
structures de pouvoir mais aussi des la
sociologie de ses acteurs à se débrider
matrice leur mode de pensée c'est très
important c'est comment comment
réfléchit ces personnes ces personnes
qui aujourd'hui parce que j'ai
fréquentés j'ai fait toutes les écoles
de la république qu'il fallait faire
j'ai suivi les parcs où je les ai suivis
dans leur parcours j'ai intégré les
institutions de pouvoir qu'ils avaient
intégré à des niveaux élevés donc en est
donc à partir de là il ya une
connaissance très forte de ces facteurs
là qui est très importante parce que
elle permet de par exemple j'ai fait en
décembre 2016 à une série de huit ou
jeanne on sait que le pouvoir de macron
ne pourrait qu'être
de nature autoritaire voire capa khalid
et je le faisais à partie une
compréhension profonde des fondements de
ce pouvoir de comment cette personne
s'était construite dans quel réseau en
france etc enfin quelle était la nature
en fait de cette de cette aventure
politique et ce qui me permet de ce qui
m'a permis et ce qui me permet
aujourd'hui de ne pas être dans comme le
font en fait la plupart des médias dans
la réaction et légumes c'est à dire a
assez il ya ce risque parce qu'il ya eu
cette proposition sur l'état d'urgence a
maintenant il ya ça mais qu'est ce qui
se passe comment ça se fait c'est comme
si moderne qu'est ce qui te dire
maintenant mais tout ça c'est en fait
c'est d'expression naturel de quelque
chose de beaucoup plus frais au profond
et structurel qui fait que c'est pas
parce qu'on va gagner on va les faire
reculer gouvernement sur telle mesure
aujourd'hui que demain il va pas y avoir
une autre qui va remplacer
structurellement il et avoir un
rétrécissement de la base et libertés
publiques en france et exercice du
pouvoir qui va être de plus en plus
autoritaire et donc et ça est-ce qu'il
ya un facteur
ce qui est un facteur exotiques qui
accélère tout ça alors je vais prendre
comme facteur exotiques le pic
énergétique par exemple un facteur
exotiques comme le réchauffement
climatique d'ailleurs qu'est ce que moi
je pense qu'à bâle mis sous tension des
appareils de pouvoir en france en
particulier là dessus on est sur un
moment où le pétrole est
structurellement un niveau assez bas et
lycées la principale enjeux énergétiques
la question nucléaire est plus ou moins
réglé et donc à partir de là je parle
vraiment en terme en terme de l'exercice
du pouvoir je dis pas que sur 160 en 150
ans mais le cette tension n'est pas
ressentie à l'échelle de l'état
aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est ça qui est en
train de dire il n'ya pas et il est rare
de voir des femmes et harmonique
christophe de margerie si j'ai travaillé
avec lui
non non
26 classes le directeur total amérique
du nord total du sud nous si j'ai
travaillé avec eux n'ont jamais
travaillé que les gens qui travaillent
dans les rôles dans l'énergie non du
tout non non jamais d'accord non non
bien sûr que non
j'aimerais bien savoir ce qui s'est
passé avec christophe de margerie ça
m'intéresserait beaucoup pour les
auditeurs il est mort
dans un labo toulon d'avion en
redécollant de moscou alors qu'il était
le patron de total
et qui c'était un des plus importants
patron un bateau gazier son monde le dit
mercredi n'est ni alou sam en un énorme
bateau portant son nom c'est fascinant
parce que c'est le genre d'affaires dans
lesquelles on a la naïveté encore c'est
quand même je trouve ça extraordinaire
qu'avec l'expérience et la connaissance
qu'on a les systèmes politiques on
continue à faire avaler le fait que
c'est que oui ça peut arriver qu'il ya
un jet privé qui tout d'un coup se
crashe à la au décollage d'un aéroport
d'une des principales puissances
gazières du monde où était le plus
important pdg
une entreprise énergétiques dans le
monde parce que christophe de margerie
d'un un homme clé est un dispositif de
la politique de puissance française et
en particulier énergétiques et et on
glisse dessus voilà c'est arrivé oui on
nous explique qu'il y avait un type qui
était bourré c'est quand même ça ce
qu'on explique son geste était dans son
chalet neige qui est passé au moment où
l'avion décollé à cheremetievo fin c'est
un aéroport international où les règles
quand même de beaux coups jouant plus
sur ce sorte d'exotisme de la fin du
russe bourré à la vodka farah qui
seraient passés par exemple sous les
gars du monde et donc il ya vraiment à
cette capacité qu'ont les pouvoirs là
pour le coup à masquer ce genre
d'information c'est très intéressant
mais il s'est beaucoup minimiser c'est
alors qu'aujourd'hui on peut le faire
sur des opérations très particulière on
peut faire plus que sur d'autres choses
très ponctuel où il ya très peu de
personnes qui vont être impliqués qui
vont permettre que ce soit là dessus on
voit très bien d'ailleurs difficultés
qu'a poutine a en tout cas le jeu c'est
plus un jeu ambigu qu'il joue avec le
polonium avec les assassinats ciblés
d'opposants ou itunes iphone est mise en
visibilité un peu étrange de judicieuse
ou sinon sur les oppose non non c'est
intéressant parce que poutine a réactivé
cet outil qui est un outil ancestrale
qui est de de la mise à mort
troubles jamais tout à fait attribuer
d'opposants pour créer un sentiment de
peur diffus qui va renforcer son pouvoir
le fonctionnement du pouvoir aux etats
unis aujourd'hui fait qu'il n'ya pas
besoin d'appliquer sur des dissidents
intérieur ou extérieur ce genre de
pratique peut être que ça a commencé
avec trump et peut-être qu'à ce moment
là assange va commencer à devenir va
être menacée par des pratiques linéaire
mais jusqu'ici par exemple quelqu'un
comme un sage n'avaient pas à craindre
de la cia ou d'autres en termes de vies
humaines il avait à craindre en termes
d'isolement une destruction de sa vie
par des moyens indirects mais pas d'
atteinte directe à sa vie quand il ya
des médias qui où quand il ya des idées
des personnalités dans certains médias
appelons alualu drones et là la gueule
mais le fait même et donc c'est
important de l'utiliser encore une fois
dans le domaine de la lutte on sait très
bien que encore une fois les structures
du pouvoir tels qu'ils existaient
jusqu'à 30 faisait que le risque
n'existait pas dire que l'on
l'application de la mort la peine de
mort par les états unis extra légale
donc pas parler processus judiciaire ne
se fait que dans et des extérieurs c'est
à dire dans des zones où les lieux
processus d'identification va être
suffisamment faible donc des terroristes
entraînés mais on va les faire au
moyen-orient avec les drones justement
état mais l'application incidents de
l'intérieur parce qu'un australien est
considéré comme appartenant au monde à
l'empiré américain n'est pas n est pas n
était pas possible enfin elle est à la
fois pour des questions de poids
politique de il n'y avait pas justement
ne serait ce que parce que si il y avait
cette dérive à ce moment là dès lors il
y aura une remise en question générale
de l'appareil de pouvoir étasunien c'est
à dire qu'on ne tourne n'aurait plus
tolérer ni ce qu'il faisait contredit
cidre intérieur nouvellement ni ce qu'il
faisait a du coup contre les terroristes
d'ailleurs une fragilisation du système
qui aurait pas font passer alors que
poutine est dans une situation beaucoup
plus où il est beaucoup plus fragile
intérieurement il a besoin de créer ce
sentiment de peur pour un stage et un
pouvoir déjà été en russie oui plusieurs
fois où ça moscou et saint-pétersbourg
vous discutez qu'il aura avec ma copine
en voyage de vacances qui était qui
travaille au teaser c'est maintenant
qu'ils étaient russes quand j'avais je
suis pas lié depuis cinq ans on m'avait
proposé le départ de travail ex modem
avec assange
j'avais hésité et et quand je
travaillais qu'assange on m'a proposé
d'aller le voir à moscou et j'ai refusé
par
pourquoi il faut comprendre que wiki
lycéens c'est un tout petit voilier
entourée d'énormes packs bourré de deux
porte conteneurs etc qui navigue un peu
dans des eaux extrêmement dangereux dans
lequel il peut se faire écraser à
n'importe quel moment c'est compliquer
ses quinze vingts personnes qu' aucune
protection d'aucun état et qui avance
seul sur un dans un monde qui est celui
du renseignement et du secret ou à
n'importe quel moment quelqu'un peut
prendre la décision d écraser et de
faire disparaître du lendemain et oui je
ne suis ravi qu à travers le soutien
public à travers toute une série
dispositif de contre-pouvoir qui sont
très fragiles et très très faible
naviguer dans ces eaux c'est tenable
jusque une certaine mesure et quand vous
faites la bascule qui est d'aller dans
un appareil d'état enfin en tout cas de
rentrer dans un espace qui est contrôlée
par l'appareil d'état comme le russe ou
du coup si vous le faites vous allez
immédiatement non seulement être sous
une potentielle emprise de cet appareil
d'état mais aussi repérer comme
potentiel ennemi d'état par des
etats-unis par les agences de
renseignement qui exercent qui vont tous
de suivre vous rentrez dans quelque
chose qui est dans ma position était
intenable était intenable et créer une
forme de de risque très important de la
même chose qui m'est arrivé la même
chose chez elle et en centrafrique en
décembre 2013 pour ma thèse pendant la
guerre civile j'ai passé un de semaine
la barre avec avec d'autres journalistes
ont enquêté et j'ai récolté des
informations sur arriva et sur l'une des
causes de la salière qui était qui était
le une mine qui était allié à la ferrure
amin qui a fait perdre 4 milliard
d'euros arrive à rire et à l'état
français c'est l'ouvrir je sais ça voilà
soit l'époque d'anne lauvergeon avec un
système de commissions rétrocommissions
qui fait danser la vie politique
française enfin tout un à ce moment là
cette personne la personne qui me donne
cette information ou la donne de façon
assez étrange elle sait que je pige pour
les inrockuptibles
et me commence à donner des informations
sur matthieu pigasse aussi s'il est
propriétaire des inrockuptibles et anzhi
je suis très copine avec matthieu
pigasse matthieu pigasse en train de
faire si ça il commence à me dire des
choses sur le fait qu'il ya la banque
lazard et son empreinte d'acier
d'arnaqué l'état sur des questions de
renégociation des dettes souveraines un
peu comme pour me me tester quoi pour
voir enfin quelque chose d'assez
trouverait me donne ses impressions en
arrivant j'ai mis un an et demi à
revenir
j'ai fait une émission sur la région
maja près où j'expliquais avec les
poings traitement médiatique peu
délirant ont parlé de génocide de guerre
civile d'accepter enfin de deux
génocides or ce n'est pas du tout la
situation etc et je parle de ces
éléments et je dis voilà j'ai vu il ya
entre autres véritables raisons claires
il ya les champs de pétrole au nord qui
sont pris entre contrôlés par des
chinois il ya d'euros de bozizé dans
l'attribution des mines d'uranium était
pas et du vin est venu pourquoi vous ne
sortez pas et je suis resté avec cette
frustration de redire binger j'aurais
dit j'ai pas les moyens aujourd'hui de
sortir mais je manque du coup je me suis
engagé pour l'émission à le faire et
j'ai eu cet engagement comme un peu
obsédé pendant un an et demi après il me
disait me suis tu je peux pas avoir
balancé ça est derrière pas faire le
travail mais j'ai mis un an et demi
avant de retourner au centrafrique me
sentir en sécurité
en allant de centrafrique et ça a pris
notamment entre autres le temps que je
révèle publiquement mon engagement après
wikileaks et que du coup ça joue un rôle
de protection en quelque sorte dans
lequel je devenais une personnalité
exposer qu'ils aient que s'il y avait un
accident de moto sur les routes de
centrafrique alors que j'étais en train
d'enquêter sur l'arrivée a eu et aura
mines ça passerait pas inaperçu et qu'à
partir de là le coût pour areva ou pour
les services qui travaillent pour areva
pour la sa direction de sécurité et qui
amènerait à susciter un accident de cet
ordre-là deviendrait soudain
suffisamment élevé pour que je me sente
à minima protégé pour aller le faire
sans risque est tout simplement
disparaître conseillère et 20 on peut
peut missionné le tueur à gages pusher
avons un petit accident mais que ce soit
des pressions des messi mais bien sûr il
ya un nombre de barbouzes qui travaille
pour arriver à la direction des
sécuritaires areva c'est quand même une
entreprise qui travaille avec le sou en
partie sous couvert du secret défense
parce qu'elle s'occupe de
l'approvisionnement nucléaire de la
france civile mais du coup aussi elles
contrôlent toute une partie des
dispositifs qui approvisionne
militairement la faim qui permettent de
faire vivre le nucléaire français du
nucléaire militaire français donc à
partir de là il ya une partie du
fonctionnement d'areva qui est
complètement intégrée à l'appareil
d'état et qui fait qu évidemment il ya
des des accidents qui peuvent intervenir
de tout ordre surtout dans des pays où
il ya une guerre civile ou en gros le
type qui va là bas enfin si d'un
accident en personne va se poser la
question comme christophe de margerie
qui se fait qu'ils meurent parce qu'il
ya un type qui était bourré sur la
l'aéroport à l'avocat bah oui on a en
russie les gens boivent de la vodka et
se bourrer la gueule y compris quand ils
travaillent dans l'aéroport
international des plus importants de la
région enfin et donc voilà donc et
pourquoi je disais ça donc de la même
façon mme exposées à ce moment là sur la
sphère snowden après avoir fait ce que
j'avais fait avec a changé et c'est pour
moi c'était un pas que je pouvais pas
faire je pouvais pas faire et je pouvais
pas faire surtout alors que je venais
arrivée des troubles sur les
interrogations trouble sur les rôles
enfin sur les interactions qui peuvent
exister entre l'appareil d'état russe et
des intermédiaires qui eux mêmes
pourraient apporter d'information etc il
ya une sorte de confusion comme ça très
forte nous donne dix existantes explosé
nous donne il est piloté pas piloter
l'état russe le surveille comment ça se
passe votre point de vue là dessus moi
j'ai pas j'ai peint démangeait pas plus
d'informations que vous ou quelqu'un
d'autre sur le sujet enfin j'ai pas
informations sur sa situation plus
qu'une petite somme qui que ce soit je
connais des gens qui connaissent très
bien qu'ils doutent pas une seconde de
sa bonne foi donc à partir de là des
gens vraiment de confiance donc j'ai
vraiment pas peur d'eux enfin de croire
qu'aucune manipulation derrière derrière
cette affaire c'est vraiment quelqu'un
qui de bonne foi a fait ce qu'il avait à
faire et qui a pris des risques énormes
et qui s'est retrouvé dans une situation
où poutine trouvé très agréable
d'instrumentaliser cette affaire pour
renvoyer les etats-unis à leurs discours
sur les droits de l'homme et
et voilà et c'est un peu le pendant de
vous connaissez la sphère de la
demi-heure vetrov innerhofer farwell ah
oui enfin des affaires far west et les
années 80 c'est l'expulsion de
l'ambassadeur c'est c'est une toile de
tout-venant électrique oui voilà par la
découverte de la taupe qui du coup
provoque l'expulsion de 50 espions
russes l'appareil s'est fait un nom sur
le centaure s'était pas qualifiée en
tant qu'espions c'était diplo adhésif le
madrid l'art de respecter les codes
diplomatique de mitterrand à l'époque
c'était de les expulser sans dire le
motif
ce qui nous à ce qui nous a valu de
reprendre la confiance auprès des états
unis et de ne pas faire perdre la face
aux russes revenons revenons à assange
on a activé un peu nos petits réseaux
aussi et tous nos amis me nous disent
que julian assange il commence à saturer
dans son ambassade et commence à te
advenir
on va dire comme un hamster dans sa roue
c'est à dire qu'il peut donc pu publier
avec le compte twitter de wikileaks
nous fait remonter des choses comme ça
non il ya une phase un peu particulière
ou l'équateur et ils n'ont vraiment fait
a décidé de couper d'essayer de couper
la connexion internet
ça à cause des révélations sur certains
de ces jeunes voilà ça s'est réglé au
bout de quelques semaines mais ça a été
une période très tendue évidemment
il faut prendre en compte donc là il
vient de célébrer andry mais c'est 50
des tensions au sein de l'ambassade de
l'équateur il faut quand même avoir
conscience que c'est des conditions qui
par certains aspects sont bien pires que
ça de la prison ils habitent dans une
petite chambre de 5 mètres carrés il a
un petit espace de travail une vingtaine
de mètres carrés en plus mais pour
prendre sa douche
il doit traverser un couloir où sont les
secrétaires et les diplomates de
l'ambassade équateur l'ensemble dans un
appartement qui a un rez-de-chaussée à
londres qui doit faire 100 150 mètres
carrés maximum dans lequel travaille
beaucoup de personnes qui ont aménagé un
espace pour lui mais où les gens
continuent à travailler où il n'ya pas
de cour intérieure il n'y a pas de c'est
pas l'ambassade telle qu'on imagine ou
l'ambassade française demain c'est
vraiment avec les murs défraîchis et ses
essais des conditions qui sont
extrêmement bien tes qui nécessairement
nécessairement ont des conséquences sur
cette situation personnelle et sur sa
vie personnelle après moi je trouve que
sur son psychisme et sur son psychisme
moi je pense qu'il ya à dire fois que
j'ai vu il était plutôt en forme ces
excités parce que ce qui arrivait mais
évidemment c'est quelqu'un qui va avoir
des périodes de tristesse de enfin bien
sûr c'est que
je pense je pense pas que ce soit en soi
un facteur de délégitimation ce qu'il
faut voir c'est c'est le cd fait que ça
sur l'organisation
assange a réussi à faire tenir une
organisation face à une pression que
leur bout de bras à bout de bras et à la
faire exister encore aujourd'hui alors
qu'au départ wikileaks et des freeriders
terre qu'ils voient la faille
technologique et ils s'engouffrent
dedans les premiers on aurait très bien
pu penser que deux mois plus tard ou
trois ou quatre ans plus tard il était
remplacé par une nouvelle organisation
beaucoup plus structurée beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus
mieux financer et ces noms assange non
seulement réussi à tenir ce rôle fond
d'un fondateur mais en plus derrière
cardinal et à se maintenir comme une
référence incontournable mais en plus il
le fait alors qu'il s'est pris une
pression hallucinante laquelle ont
essayé de détruire son organisation est
lui-même par tous les moyens possibles
et non seulement c'est assez admirable
mais surtout que le facteur le seul
facteur qui explique sa outre son
intelligence c'est tout simplement son
courage c'est à dire sa capacité à un
moment à ne pas sain en fait les états
unis ont fait une erreur en l'empêchant
d'institutionnaliser wikileaks qu'il
aurait peut-être fait c'est qu'ils l'ont
forcé à rester un pirate et en restant
un pirate a à ne pas se soumettre à la
moindre règle de quelque ordre que ce
soit dans son ambassade où la limite et
juridictionnelles complète et par cette
radicalité ces sacs en fait qu'il a fait
survivre à café sur wikileaks et la
radicalité complète qui fait qu'ils
n'auront pas peur de publier
l'information d'où qu'elle vienne pour
peu qu'elles servent l'intérêt commun
selon et soit de valeur qui fasse que
les citoyens méritent les de les
découvrir donc 7 c'est assez
extraordinaire d'avoir créé une
radicalité enfin que les états unis et
créer une radicalité de cet ordre là
quasiment irrésistible qui font que même
si aujourd'hui on a des organismes comme
de l'acier lady enfin dès qu'ils sont
très structurés comme beaucoup de fonds
qui travaillent de façon très
très très recommandable ils n'ont pas
pris cette place là qui restent occupées
par cette petite organisation qui
fonctionne comme un petit bateau qui
continue à avancer et dans laquelle
enfin il continua plus que bien des
services à extraordinaire à l'humanité
la position de la france maintenant avec
macro concernant l'asile avec la
saintonge et snowdon
assange a un fils en france quand même à
un pied le regroupement familial comment
ça se passe pour un lanceur de détention
soit majeur mais ce serait pas mal de
déposer une demande en ce sens françois
hollande nous avait eu c'est moi qui
m'étais occupé de cette affaire avait
refusé la demande d'asile de d'assange
dans 45 minutes après un examen
approfondi ce qui était quand même assez
facilement en prenons excuses sur sur la
fin en prenant en faisant référence à la
sphère suédoise c'était sale excuses en
broyat mandat d'arrêt européen donc à
partir de là on ne peut pas on peut pas
les accueillir
ce monde cette affaire étant tombée et
la manipulation et en étant démontrer
théoriquement rien ne s'opposerait à ce
qu'on rende en donne d'asie la france à
assange la nationalité et la légion
d'honneur selon moi tout simplement
pourquoi cet être en juin 2015 au risque
de sa vie révèle avec des personnes qui
travaillent avec wikileaks à l'époque
que les et des principales personnalités
politiques françaises y compris les
présidents de la république françois
hollande nicolas sarkozy jacques chirac
leur téléphone personnel ont été
espionnés par la nsa en continu non
seulement ça mais que par ailleurs toute
entreprise française participant à un
appel d'offre supérieure à 250 millions
d'euros n'importe où dans le monde et
est systématiquement et d'espionner afin
de faire afin de saboter leurs offres
combien de milliers d'emplois ont été
détruits à cause de ces lits positif et
sauvés par l'action d'un singe qui une
fois qui a révélé cette information
donner des outils à la france pour
défendre sa souveraineté et mettre fin à
ces pratiques illégales que il faut
quand même replacé rien comme pour ce
geste au delà de tout ce qu'il a fait
par ailleurs sur la guerre en irak et en
afghanistan et c'est pas rien pour ce
geste nous avons une dette énorme les
avis de sept personnes on parle même
plus des questions familiales de sa
situation personnelle de geste
humanitaire on parle de reconnaissance
face à quelqu'un qui a risqué sa vie
pour l'intérêt de la france pour
l'intérêt de la france et lui l'a fait
non pas pour l'intérêt de la france mais
parce qu'il considérait que ça servait
le bien commun dans son ensemble mais en
l'occurrence ça a servi ce pays qui du
coup devrait agir entre donné évidemment
je comprends bien que patrice de maistre
mérite la légion d'honneur etc mais il
ya un moins bon comme ce fossé interrogé
sur sur sur l'écart que l'on que l'on
tient et que l'on accepte qu'on accepte
à la fois non seulement pas l'état mais
la société les médias la société
française du moins est-ce que l'appareil
d'état fait acte de forfaiture
gagne trahison de la part de hollande
qui d'ailleurs le jour juste une
parenthèse comme on est en direct il
faut pas hésiter à la communauté de
faire remonter leurs questions mais nous
on a des coûte je te relance pendant
françois hollande en fait tu
sais pas si le terme
d'accor pareil intercultures question ça
veut dire déjà valley
pour moi c'est une forme de trahison
mais la question qui est ce que trahison
forfaiture à ces deux postes c'est voilà
françois hollande acceptent d'échanger
par texto avec moi ce qui est quand même
révélateur par texto locaux si je risque
de gêner assange pour me dire qu'il faut
absolument qu'on se voit au lendemain de
ses chiffres et chiffré ou pas l'une aux
textos texto pour
j'ai hésité à lui dire est ce que vous
pouvez installer signal je me suis
peut-être un peu déplacé au président de
la république depuis mai mais on a hélas
est d'ailleurs à mon avis c'est ce qui
explique que derrière c'est la rencontre
n'est pas intervenu parce qu'évidemment
c'est immédiatement intercepté et donc
enfin il ya l'ambassadeur des états unis
qui a appliqué qui dit qu'est ce que
vous foutez et il voulait que l'on se
rencontre ils disaient qu'ils voulaient
qu'on se rencontre pour que pour qu'on
n'étudie qu'est ce qui pouvait être fait
pour ce qui pouvait être fait pour
assange
c'était une ambassadrice 1 c'est une
ambassadrice à l'époque
j'ai des parents compris
contrairement à contrairement à beaucoup
d'hommes politiques français
en ascension et notamment emmanuel
macron qui était young leaders enfin
qu'un séjour des changes d'un an dans le
dispositif de lobbying et d' influence
le plus important des états unis qui se
concentrent dans les appareils d'état
pour bien sûr pour après établir des
liens qui se massait le soft au ces le
soft power du 21e siècle ce genre de
dispositif c'est sur le point de départ
bien sûr et une fois que vous avez ça
vous pouvez construire de façon quand
vous avez des ambassades avec plusieurs
centaines d'employés vous pouvez tisser
un réseau qui est extrêmement un labo et
qui fait que vous allez avoir beaucoup
de difficulté à vous opposer à
ce genre de politique et que quand vous
vous opposez à ce genre de politique
vous allez avoir beaucoup de moyens
d'influencé directe indirecte qui vont
permettre de diaboliser la personne qui
va c'est pour ça qu'il faut encore des
pirates au 21ème siècle
moi je pense qu'il faudra des pirates
dans tout
dans toute société il faut des pirates y
faut des pirates parce que les pirates
incarne un espace de liberté et il n'y a
aucune société qui soit en surplus
liberté et à partir de là il faut faudra
toujours défendre et s'engager enfin
pour des formes pour pour protéger ces
personnes qui m'ont prennent la tangente
quels que soient les motifs d'ailleurs
pour réussir sourire un modèle
alternatif jusqu'où tu es prêt à payer
le prix de ta liberté
ça paraît bateau comme ça comme question
ça dépend de l'enjeu hier que moi j'ai
eu la chance de tomber sur cette
aventure par exemple tulik il y avait un
parcours derrière qui me permettait de
me brancher mais
qu'ils aient que je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de personnes aujourd'hui qui
rêvent de s'engager comme je lé fais qui
ont juste pas eu la chance de faire qui
n'ont pas eu les mots les outils ou
l'espace un moment donc à partir de là
je pense qu'on peut aller très loin
quand on se retrouve face à une cause
qui en vaut la peine et mais ça dépend
de la cause de cette fois il faut pas
dans une posture sacrificielle pour le
pôle idée du sacrifice pourquoi parce
que ça ça me construire enfin juste être
dans une police n'était pas ça ça vous
amène à faire le djihad et vous faire
sauter pour pour pour rien en fait donc
faux pas il faut c'est pas la question
est-ce que aaron swartz c'était une
position sacrificielle non c'est
quelqu'un qui était détruit alors qu'il
n'était pas du tout une pollution
sacrifices et c'est peut-être là la
grandeur du scandale assange quand il
prend les risques qu'il prend ici c'est
qu'il prend et il s'est hissé il sait
qu'il est prend il les prend en
conscience et c'est très bien que demain
il peut se faire assassiner il peut se
faire il peut faire il peut voir sa vie
complètement détruites et il fait ce pas
en conscience parce qu'ils voient très
bien questionné alors une sorte c'est
quelqu'un qui qui détruit par un pouvoir
qui eux qui décident d'excéder
complètement toutes les toutes les
limites et de et et qui dans cette sorte
de folie répressive est prêt à faire ce
à faire faire ce suicide est un garçon
de 27 ans pour avoir pour avoir pour
avoir rien fait en fait pour avoir
contribué au bien commun sans à aucun
moment j'en touche les mighty a ouvert
derrière c'est avec les mighty qui
couvrent derrière évidemment avec sa
hâte de vous retrouver la lâcheté des
institutions viables
et ça c'est moi j'ai payé un prix un
moment qui est mon avis était beaucoup
trop excessif parce que je suis rentré
dans un dans cette lutte armée et armés
par des dispositifs qui théoriquement
deuxième protégé qui était notamment le
fait de travailler l'équipe de défense
de wikileaks épaves equity mise
directement c'est vrai j'ai pris un
risque somme toute relativement calcul
est énorme par rapport à l'endroit d'où
je venais etc mais mais qui faisait que
normalement des dispositifs de
protection devaient s'appliquer et quand
je me suis rendu compte que les
dispositifs de protection qui sont
votées qui sont inscrits dans la
constitution qui sont votées par les
lois de l'état ne s'appliquent et plus
et ne s'appliquait pas et faisait qu'on
était beaucoup plus exposés que ce qu'on
devrait l'être alors qu'on fait une
mission de service public quel que soit
un avocat théoriquement je suis depuis
peu mais avant j'étais conseiller
juridique à oka théoriquement vous
pouvez défendre mesrine de hitler qui
voulait sa
mairie non pardon ça vous un peu ça vous
ça vous
vous ne devenez pas votre client et on a
besoin et c'est ce client aura toujours
besoin avocat il faut qu'il y ait un
avocat et a donc vous êtes censés
protéger moi je me suis rendu compte
qu'il y avait une confusion complète des
rôles non seulement pour moi à une
époque où en effet j'étais pas avocat
comme si je leur ai dit que j'avais un
certain dr nnoaham enfants pouvaient
comprendre non mais y compris des gens
comme baltasar garzon le juge espagnol
qui a fait tomber pineau chet enfin qu'à
faire et épisodes 7 et qui était un qui
dirigeait l'équipe de défense de
wikileaks qui se faisait arrêter et
menaces et aux états unis pour avoir
pris la défense vous faire pour avoir
envisagé de prendre la défense de
snowdon avant qu'ils apprennent moi qui
me retrouve à paris menacé par cette
même personne qui m'ait donné
d'informations sur pied à ces arrivages
du mois après la centrafrique et le
lendemain que j'écris pour la première
fois de façon non crypté que je m'étais
engagé dans dans cette affaire avec
julian assange may cry pour me demander
un rendez vous urgent me reçoit au fond
du sélect
dans un
plein mois d'août en plein cagnard dans
un espace complètement vide à 15 heures
avec des énormes lunettes en laisse et
l'ue m me fait montré un visage tuméfié
et me dit j'ai parlé en france tout ça
parce que j'ai rencontré un sens parce
que j'ai décidé de m'engager en tant que
juriste pour essayer de faire avancer
cette cause sans avoir de rapport avec
les activités de publication de
wikileaks enfin c'est qu'on en est
arrivé là et qu'elle me dit après enfin
ils essaient de me vanter une histoire
d'intimidation en fait j'imagine parce
que ayant été au quai d'orsay etc il y
avait une peur que je révèle
l'information quand on est sur ce genre
de situations avec un gosse de 23 ans se
retrouve face à ce genre de pression
pour avoir fait quelque chose qui est
non seulement parfaitement légale mais
en plus légitime qui à aucun moment à
dépasser la moins dure des mails vous
retrouvez que vous voyez qui a une
dysfonction qui est similaire à celle
d'arnie charte il en fait à détruire et
à détruire pour protéger de façon
illégitime et illégal un pouvoir qui est
en train de rentrer dans une
excroissance démesurée et à partir de là
à partir de là que les actes que vous
prenez les risques que vous prenez et
c'est ce que dit assange de cette fois
ne doivent pas être saluée comme étant
glorieux héroïco quoi que ce soit c'est
leiris et le fait qu'il faille prendre
un risque pour avancer un cd rancio dans
cette direction qui doit être condamnée
qui doit susciter indignation qui doit
c'est pas c'est pas le est ce que fait
assange ce que j'ai fait dans ma toute
petite mesure c'est déjà ce qu'ils sont
normaux qui devrait être qui ne devrait
pas impliquer une irisation une
martyrisation autres il devrait pas
impliquer la violence quelle qu'elle
qu'elle produit de la stratégie pour
faire sortir assange devant l'ambassade
c'est quoi maintenant là c'est une
question politique aux litiges à mettre
m maintenant aujourd'hui les états unis
ne peuvent plus les autorités
étasuniennes ne peuvent plus cacher le
fait que cette personne est détenue
depuis 5 ans et 7 ans l'ont enfin
presque 7 si on considère
de résidence surveillée et c'est pour
une affaire qui n'existe pas qui était
affaire suédoise et qui le fait parce
qu'il a publié des documents qui
révélait des crimes de guerre et crimes
contre l'humanité à partir de là ils
doivent assumer le fait qu'ils le font
dans cette mesure qui les persécute et
de ce fait le royaume uni doit assumer
que le seul prisonniers politiques
détenus en europe occidentale et reconnu
comme tel par l'onu il est
sur son territoire au coeur de londres à
50 mètres du à de harrods et justifier
pourquoi et là c'est le rôle de la
société et des médias quels que soient
leurs préjugés quelles que soient leurs
considérations sur la personnalité
d'assurance sur ses dernières
publications et c'est sur ça à
s'interroger et qui doivent s'interroger
sur leurs responsabilités et sur le rôle
qu'ils doivent jouer pour imposer à
l'état qu'elles soient en france aux
états unis ou huawei nuit pour qu'il
veut mettre fin à cette situation c'est
notre responsabilité mais c'est un
rapport de force politique c'est une
question juridique ça tombe bien c'était
un caisson que je comptais me posez
c'est est-ce que nous français pour vous
faire changer les choses sur l'accueil
des lanceurs d alerte si oui comment en
gros c'est un appel à ce que le pouvoir
français fassent pression sur le pouvoir
politique mais bien sûr là c'est une
question de séverac question de rapport
de forces politique c'est une question à
part de forces politiques et
organisations du rapport de force on va
arriver à la fin notre interview on va
déjà annoncé le prochain live
qui arrive incessamment sous peu avec
david koubbi stéphanie ribot on a une
dernière question qu'on pose à tous à
tous nos invités qui récurrentes s'est
laissé un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
une bouteille à la mer sur internet qui
va devenir un pays stable grâce aux
serveurs de la nsa et un message à faire
passer
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
pour ce que tu veux quoi fait pas partie
comment cela fait pas partie des jeunes
générations je pense qu'on a des
ondelettes rachat classe et je pense que
tu es un passager clandestin
intergénérations je pense que tu dois te
sentir certain temps donc je ne jeûne
est extrait pas de la plèbe je te
demande simplement un message qui ne
perd pas de son de son sens de sa sève
cours du temps quelque chose de
impérissable réfléchit bien
l'indifférence et un énorme facteur de
d'exclusion et de violences dire que la
passivité politique est un acte et aérer
un acte est un acte en fait est un acte
est un acte des structures là le je m'en
foutisme la mise à distance l'absence
d'intérêt pour les questions politiques
sociétales économiques pour l'exclusion
l'injustice la violence c'est des
producteurs et des facteurs qui
nourrissent en fait c'est ces
dispositifs et ses
essais et cap et à partir de là il ya
ceux des responsabilités c'est se
déresponsabiliser c'est prendre une
grande responsabilité dans dans la
dégradation de notre société est ce que
ça pourra susciter sa mort a suscité de
1 et c'est la passivité de millions de
personnes qui va susciter
qui va susciter si vite et loin des
violences la et dans le même temps je
comprends parfaitement ce qu'ils ne
trouvent pas à l'espace et moi même je
me suis retrouvé un moment et notamment
avant wikileaks dans un moment où je
trouvais pas les les outils pour propos
pour lutter en quelque sorte et et c'est
pour ça que je parle de wikileaks comme
un miracle un moment qui me permet à
main porter une lutte qui correspondent
à mes idéaux et là il ya une grande
responsabilité pour le coup d'une élite
mais d'une élite qui est pas des dites
actuelles qui est juste de la
constitution de personnes qui parce
qu'ils ont des moyens vont un moment que
ce soit intellectuel économique aux
autres ou un moment ouvrir la voie et
c'est là où les ou des personnes comme
un seul sens très importante parce
qu'elles vont ouvrir la voie à d'autres
personnes et vont faire que ce qu'ils
veulent vont pouvoir sortir de cette
responsabilités de cette
déresponsabilisation et s'ils ne le font
pas ce sera ce sera un choix de leur
part tant qu'on ne donne pas on offre
pas les outils aux personnes pour pour
agir
on se soumet en fait à ce discours au
nizan toute façon je pourrais rien faire
donc quoi faire me d investir donc créer
ces espaces pour ceux qui en ont les
moyens et pour ceux qui en sont
extérieures continuer à s'informer et à
prendre conscience de du fait qu'il y
aura durera toujours des injustices et
violences extrêmement grande dans toutes
les sociétés quelle que soit leur forme
et que et qu' il devenir indifférence et
c'est s'en prendre à partie responsable
je pense que c'est ce qu'il faut
renault bang bang bang route merci
beaucoup merci et prochain direct live
dans 30 minutes merci clap de fin
[Musique]
m